okay now it's all about special sellers
and fabulous fruits perfect for special
occasions cooking at home for special
occasions falls into two camps sit-down
at fairs where the food's a bit more
formal and relax parties where dishes
are laid out and people can choose what
they want to eat and when if you're
cooking for a party always make dishes
that are colorful vibrant and exciting
to eat so you'll grab your guests
attention and really wow their taste
buds my first dish has plenty of
attitude enough for any special occasion
a flavor packed green papaya salad this
is a great salad to serve at a party
it's delicious and robust enough to last
the whole evening without wilting
first off these are a little dried
shrimp you can buy them anywhere they
smell almost sort of the seabed into the
pestle mortar for this salad inspired by
my travels across Thailand I'm starting
by making my wonderfully spicy paste a
little salt in there in just break them
up this place is like a staple
ingredient in Thailand that's what we're
looking for almost like a powder right
next just one clove of garlic slice up
the garlic and get that into the pestle
mortar Birds Eye chili incredibly hot
powerful but Wow it does give an amazing
kick to the paste in to the mix now a
couple tablespoons of brown caster sugar
that softens the blow with a chilli and
then just to get that nice sour taste a
little bit of hot water into this
tamarind paste it's really tart but
sweet pace one table is proven in fish
sauce now it's got that almost sort of
pickly smell slightly salty but the
flavor is intense two tablespoons and
bring that together and give it a really
good mix
some lime juice and half another touch
of of tartness the place is nice and
thick and fragrant but it's got the heat
the sounds the tartness incredible green
papaya stand it up give it a little peel
you can find green papaya in local Asian
shops and bigger supermarkets and as it
doesn't wilt like more delicate veg it's
perfect for robust salads like this
my greatest no that's what I want
these thin slivers next a nice rich
sweet banana a lot nice some carrot
carrot gives it another texture
[Music]
now little that mixing turns that off
with Thai basil and fresh coriander Thai
basil is a much more fragrant basil it's
stronger and is slightly thicker as well
like the pine and tamarind paste you can
get Thai basil in good supermarkets and
independent Asian stores but no basil
works well too
next prepare the crunchy topping pan on
and toast some peanuts chop the nuts
break easily nice crunch and then they
go roll them around the pan gas off and
just dip them out now for the exciting
part I'm going to dress the sellers nice
spoon of dressing in to the papaya and
exhaling
and finally our nice general sprinkling
roasted nuts
and that is one delicious very fragrant
very robust green papaya salad so easy
to make and guaranteed not to go limp a
perfect party salad and with such
incredible colors textures and bold
exciting flavors it's sure to grab your
guests attention when you're putting
together a feast for the family or
friends is great to have some
bulletproof salads in your cooking
repertoire here are three more of my
favorites to set you up first my
delicious chopped salad
sliced cherry tomatoes in half and add
to the bowl along with chopped red
pepper and finely diced shallots next
slice salami into strips and add follow
with nutty chickpeas
and smooth Edam cheese going to
matchsticks building up different tastes
textures and flavors as you go next add
chicory for deliciously bitter bite
then chop crisp romaine lettuce and add
for the dressing finely chopped garlic
add sherry vinegar a shake or spicy
Worcestershire sauce castor sugar and
olive oil then simply whisk pour the
dressing over the salad and mix so that
everything is thoroughly coated finally
sprinkle with dried oregano for an
aromatic finish a salad so easy if you
can chop you can make it with such
delicious results it has to be tasted to
be believed
[Music]
my next simple salad that's perfect for
a party is green bean salad with mustard
dressing
[Music]
for the dressing wrap a whole bulb of
garlic in foil and roast it in a hot
oven next add top and tail green beans
to salted boiling water and cook for
just a couple of minutes this is called
blanching and keeps the things
deliciously crunchy strain the beans and
refreshing cold water this stops the
cooking process so they stay crisp and
green next remove your garlic from the
oven cut off the head and squeeze out
all the glorious garlic which has gone
creamy mellow and divine in the oven
then simply add sharp white wine vinegar
a dollop of Dijon mustard and sweet
runny honey
season and poured a good glug of olive
oil that weighs
[Music]
at the crunchy blonds green beans
and top with toasted almonds for a
lovely nutty note and crunchy texture
mix well and serve heavenly mustard
vinaigrette with a hint of mellow roast
garlic stunning green beans dressed to
perfection
[Music]
my next salad that's great for any big
bash is roasted red pepper lentil and
herb salad
[Music]
and three lentils two vegetable stock
along with a bay leaf and bought for 15
minutes three lentils are perfect for
sellers have a great meaty flavor and a
delicious bite for texture next chopped
sweet red peppers place on a baking tray
along with diced courgette drizzle over
olive oil season and roast in a hot oven
[Music]
to assemble the salad place the drain
lentils in a large bowl then add olive
oil
[Music]
they've chopped some blush Tomatoes
[Music]
take the roasted red peppers and
courgettes from the oven and add along
with chopped avocado as it's delicious
creamy flesh give the salad a lovely
contrast season then for a big herby hit
chop a handful of chives and basil and
add
squeezed over lemon juice and mix earthy
aromatic and packed full of goodness
absolutely stunning sir with roasted
meats and fish or perfect eatin just by
itself three incredible salads all
bursting with flavor color and health so
quick and easy to prep and Pudsey
delicious you'll be making them every
day not just on a special occasion
Plus welcome back to my ultimate cookery
course coming up I'll be using snappers
fruits to create a show-stopping dessert
every time I get to put one of these
together it's like a sort of little
jewelry box
but first the key to dishes that really
impress is amazingly fresh ingredients
and it's essential to get the best for
your money when you're out shopping so
make sure whatever you're buying it
looks smells and feels really good and
if you get the chance and taste it
before you buy it
a great-tasting salad starts with
fantastic salad leaves and when it comes
to all things green there's little dr.
Steve ruffle doesn't know I think I am
obsessed with South I'm obsessed
primarily with watercress that's in my
heart Castillo got a PhD of watercress a
doctorate in salad we should all take a
leaf out his book then he's not only
been studying sudden leaves for over 30
years
he's been growing them so he really
knows he's rocket from his romaine there
are literally thousands of varieties of
salad things like the Tavian lettuce red
veined spinach wild rocket sorrel we
grow virtually everything outdoors and
and we follow the seasons so we're not
forcing the leaves we don't give them
too much fertilizer or irrigation we try
to grow them a little bit slower and
that's the way to get the best flavor
and the best quality of leaf will
harvest a crop cut it in the morning
it's then on the road going out to
customers to be on the Shelf the next
day this is a great leaf baby leaf
spinach and we call it baby leaf yeah
quite literally because we cut it when
it's still at a baby stage these are
baby pea shoots we'll put something like
three or four hundred pea seeds into the
seed bed and then in as little as 12 14
days they've grown to a sort of a crop
like this they've got the flavor of
fresh peas a bit of sweetness and they
and they got a really nice soft velvety
leaf texture this is baby watercress
which is my favorite salad crop of them
all watercress is special because by
definition it's grown in pure flowing
water fresh watercress has got that
fantastic pungent peppery flavor in
Victorian London it was known as poor
man's bread whereby a lot of workers
would start the day with a watercress
sandwich and if they couldn't afford
bread they just ate the watercress
straight it is an amazing full of flavor
I can't eat enough sell it obsessed
thieves
spot on there's hundreds of salad leaves
available with different textures tastes
and colors here are five my favorite
everyday salad leaves and don't forget
some of them are delicious cooked -
little gem sweet and crisp and an
amazingly dense heart these many cause
lettuces are great simply braised in the
oven or use the leaves as scoops for
delicious chili beef filling mustard
leaves pungent spicy and full of vitamin
C these are a staple in Asian dishes and
are fantastic stir fried or steamed
lambs leaf full of tangy flavor and with
incredible springy stems great for
hearty robust salads or simply paired
with fish for a healthier simple supper
rocket these distinctive peppery leaves
are actually classed as a herb and are
perfect in soups or with fruits and are
full of iron finally chicory or on leave
these tightly packed red or white leaves
have a deliciously bitter taste and are
great wrapped in ham or alongside shine
blue cheeses I think when you're
shopping for salads you can just shop
with your eyes you know if it looks
fresh and healthy tasty it is you want
to look for bright colors I like to see
leaves with a bit of moisture on them
sounds like to be kept cold and moist
basically so when you buy a packaged
salad put it in the fridge and if you
don't use it all in one go
roll up the bag to exclude surplus air
put it back in the fridge keep it cold
there's so much choice of writing out
there I really do think people should be
more adventurous in their choice of
salads here both what they choose to try
and eat and and what they do with them
so get yourself some ingredients use
them boldly and your studded leaves can
really take center stage
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips dorbz are a fantastic ingredient
when you want a special salad that
really impresses here's how to prepare
them do not be intimidated trying to get
the scallop out i'ma show you how easy
it is to take them out and how much more
exciting is to get them fresh in the
shell so just face it the dessert spoon
and a blunt knife put the knife in to
the bottom and you just twist open till
the knife up set doesn't cut into the
scallop meat run the knife on the top to
the base off with a lid no flesh on
there and then from there that's cool
just scallops skirt all you do is just
peel that forward and get the spoon to
run down the back of the shell and the
idea is to remove that little bit of
muscle that holds the scallop on to the
bottom shelf bang it pops out that's the
top the small side of the bottom there's
the muscle there and your thumb just
slides neatly in there and run your
fingers round and you just pop out Scott
up and look bang beautiful this bit here
is called the skirt no use doesn't taste
everything now that's the coral you can
slice that off dry it in the oven and
use it as a powder for your risottos or
even seasoning fish with but that's
their money these just need to be rinsed
under cold water dried and ready for the
pan
tomatoes are another salad staple his
how to skin them for extra refinement
score each one with a cross at the
bottom blanch in boiling water for a
minute
then shot them in cold water and the
skins will easily peel away pomegranates
are a fabulous fruit by adding glamour
to salads or desserts the trick to
getting the seeds out slice in half
lengthways makes its around the edge
turn upside down over a bowl and using a
large spoon whack as hard as you can to
release the seeds to take fabulous fruit
puts the next level my tip is to add
sophisticated cornell's of ice cream or
lemon mascarpone simply dip two metal
spoons in hot water
scoop shape and add and after baking
never throw out your leftover pastry
it's easy transformed into grapefruit or
savory party nibbles roll out break
Parmesan or sprinkle over your favorite
fruit roll and then just slice and bake
[Music]
as any chef knows at the end of a meal
you want to leave your guests on a high
with a spectacular dessert so when
you're cooking for a special occasion
and want to make an impact it's great to
have a fabulous fruit dessert up your
sleeve
[Music]
my last recipe looks sensational and
tastes just as good
raspberry milfoil desserts should always
have that wow factor and this dish is
incredibly simple to prepare but it
tastes and looks absolutely stunning
first off puff pastry you can buy
fabulous puff pastry now a non-stick
baking tray and just lay the puff pastry
on the tray I want to get the top of the
puff pastry camera eyes so we're going
to dust it in icing sugar now move 40
means a thousand layers just lightly
dust the top of the puff pastry with
icing sugar we're gonna start off in a
hot oven at 220 for the first six or
seven minutes and then ten minutes at
190 into the oven now for the filling
fresh vanilla cream in you start
whisking what the cream whisk
nice and thick but look at all that nice
fresh vanilla seeds in there next a nice
scraping of orange zest
all right look cure don't whisk that in
fold it in and that stops the cream and
separating lovely now
take that out of the bowl and put it
into a piping bag unwrapped over your
hands in a way that you're trading is
little pocket snip off the end nozzle in
load up the bag
just twist slowly there's no where the
bag is nice and full and firm chill your
gorgeous vanilla and orange cream in the
fridge until you're ready to pipe it wow
that is beautiful
there's the layers there that's the
middle for a pub gently lift it up onto
the board
I'll slide into three serrated edge
knife
Wow
beautiful start deciding on how you
gonna layer it that bit there that's
nice and firm for my brace that's nice
and decorative for the top and that bit
there for the middle take our you cream
and put a little touch or cream there
and that just sticks that down it stops
it from sliding pipe very carefully a
nice thin layer of cream around the
outside and come back into the middle
beautiful now they're a Swiss sit them
two by two now this layer I'll turn it
upside down and put the camera eyes part
of a pastry on top of the raw spruce
every time I get to put one of these
together it's like a sort of little
jewelry box again cream squeezed from
the back of the bag so you got control
there a Swiss too much
so I put another layer of cream on top
those rasmus because I want some height
with my final layer well it's worth dive
in there put the lid on it mmm and push
that down there you have a beautiful
stunning simple meal for a dessert to
die for and like all the dishes in my
optimum cookery course I guarantee it
will taste as sensational as it looks
[Music]
I've now shown you 100 recipes to stake
your life on smells amazing simple and
accessible dishes together to give you
confidence in the kitchen hold the drum
the slice straight through and help cook
yourself into a better chef really
important to season the mins before you
cook it I've shared essential tips and
insider knowledge that actually smelled
much but the flavor they give off is
extraordinary
on everything from shopping for great
ingredients don't be fine get your nose
right into it to my kitchen equipment
essentials the secret of brazing is
having a really nice thick durable pan
and my optimum of cooking lessons key
mantras to make you fearless in the
kitchen
stripping away all the complexity so you
can whip up tasty and delicious dishes
with ease just finish it with a little
tail spoon of that sauce and most
importantly learn to enjoy cooking at
home incredible many of these amazing
recipes are on my app please check out
the App Store for details so what are
you waiting for go on get cooking
you